avec 7000 exposants et une centaine de
pays représentés le Salon international
de l'alimentaire est un rendez-vous
incontournable pour les entreprise du
secteur pierre Menini dirigeant
d'alpérelle y a installé son stand ça
nous permet d'identifier des
possibilités pour l'export notamment sur
leocal on a fait des des jolis contacts
notamment sur l'Asie qui est assez
Friant des des produits français
artisanaux alpérel réalise un chiffre
d'affaires de 650000 € dont 10 % à
l'export une société au ambitions
internationales mais bien ancré dans les
zvelines son positionnement à trappe lui
offre plusieurs avantages pour s'ouvrir
sur la Normandie et donc toute la
logistique export avec le port du Havre
mais également pouvoir fournir assez
rapidement les restaurants et les
épicerie fin à Paris spécificité de ce
glacier sa production est 100 %
artisanale et naturelle en 2017 tout le
lait servant à fabriquer ses produits
proviendra des lteries de Grignon pierre
Menini et son équipe laissent aussi
libre à leur créativité et confectionne
des parfums originaux leur ambition dans
5 ans toujours bien ancré en
île-defance plus reconnu qu'on ne l'
aujourd'hui être reconnu comme un acteur
régional important et puis avec une
petite notoriété à
l'export